Cuál es la situación de Derechos Humanos
en nuestra región actualmente En cuáles
materias se puede hablar de mejorías y
En cuales de retroceso
Sí muy buenas noches efectivamente
tenemos una región bastante compleja en
términos de mejorías realmente
vemos con esperanza digamos en algunos
países gobiernos que al menos en el
discurso están planteando un discurso de
combatir la desigualdad y ahí podemos
señalar acá por ejemplo en Colombia
podemos señalar el caso también de chile
sin embargo lo que más nos preocupa las
organizaciones que estamos acá reunidas
son precisamente los retrocesos verdad
retrocesos en términos de la
militarización en muchos de los países
por ejemplo en el caso de México en el
caso del Salvador países que han
restringido los espacios de
participación política por supuesto el
caso de Nicaragua el caso de Venezuela
que son prácticamente gobiernos
completamente cerrados y como en
términos estructurales tenemos una
desigualdad que caracteriza toda la
región Y cómo esa desigualdad está
afectando a grupos históricamente
discriminados Como por ejemplo las
mujeres los pueblos indígenas la
población afrodescendiente encontramos
además otra problemática muy seria que
es el fenómeno de las migraciones verdad
como tenemos migraciones masivas la
mayoría hacia el norte Pero algunas por
ejemplo en Centroamérica observamos
migraciones lo que llamamos hacia el sur
verdad personas de Nicaragua personas
del Salvador de Honduras migrando hacia
Costa Rica y hacia Panamá Entonces es un
fenómeno que nos preocupa muchísimo y
por otra parte el crimen organizado que
es un fenómeno regional Que
prácticamente afecta a toda la región
entonces
realmente eso encontramos algunos países
en los que en el discurso se pretende
avanzar por ejemplo en términos de
violencia de género en términos de
garantías de personas LG de lgbtiq más
pero en realidad hay problemas
estructurales que todavía no se están
abordando y que generan estos problemas
que estamos que estoy señalando en
algunas naciones ya usted lo estaba
mencionando los Derechos Humanos son
violados por los gobiernos y por las
autoridades responsables de defenderlos
quién puede entonces ser garante en
estos territorios
Bueno la verdad es que la garantía
siempre la tiene los estados y esa es
una preocupación existen sistemas
internacionales de protección por
ejemplo el sistema interamericano o el
sistema de Naciones Unidas pero
realmente
pues son sistemas que son débiles porque
tienen que respetar la soberanía de los
estados y aunque son sistemas que emanan
recomendaciones que en muchos casos son
vinculantes nuevamente se regresa al
estado y si los estados los gobiernos no
responden pues simplemente estas
recomendaciones se quedan en el papel
corresponden todo caso pues en primer
lugar a los Estados garantizar los
Derechos Humanos pero también a la
comunidad internacional
no solamente a través del uso por
ejemplo el sistema interamericano de
protección de Derechos Humanos sino a
los Estados en los diálogos bilaterales
que tienen entre ellos poner los temas
de Derechos Humanos en la agenda Brian
agendas bilaterales en términos
económicos pero en términos de Derechos
Humanos muchos se deja de lado Entonces
sí hay una responsabilidad primaria que
no podemos evadir y son los gobiernos
pero la comunidad Nacional los
organismos internacionales También
tienen una responsabilidad